[Music]
directors consortium is an executive
program for directors of public
companies or people who serve on boards
that are likely to go public this
program emerged as a collaboration
between the business school and the law
school drawing on both the expertise
that our faculty have around the many
facets of being successful in business
and the legal foundation of the role of
a director and their legal
responsibilities I bought probably fifty
companies have been bought myself ten
times pretty much thought I knew
everything and then go through the
process I realized well I don't know
everything just seeing how other
directors deal with similar situations
as board directors you get yourself in
big trouble when you stop learning and
when you start thinking that you know a
lot you do but you don't know at all
there are two distinctive features to
the directors consortium the classroom
setting which allows for intensive
interaction among the faculty and the
participants and the second is the
grounding of the program and research
which provides directors with frameworks
and evidence to address the questions
that they face in the boardroom the
faculty here is very engaging they teach
in a manner that you are not just
thinking about what they're teaching but
also reflecting upon your experiences
they have a way to elicit conversation
we've tried to keep the cohort small
because we expect that the learning
doesn't happen only from the experts and
them sharing what they're seeing on the
research front but also in a
collaborative fashion this provides a
good forum for us to kind of let our
hair down and say this is my situation
that's your situation our perspectives
come together to give each participant a
really rich understanding of the nuance
the content aims to provide fundamentals
and foundations but also to keep the
board members abreast of all of the
emerging issues facing corporations
cutting edge issues like cyber security
challenges facing the Audit Committee
how to manage risk how artificial
intelligence is going to play a role and
what that means for directors and the
boards they serve on the optional
modules relate to basic principles of
accounting and basic principles of
Finance this is for board members who
might feel rusty about these topics as
well as board members who might not be
as well-versed with these topics these
are rules of thumb these are tools
toolkits that will be applicable not
just today but years from today and they
apply across every board I'm gonna go by
with lots of ideas for best practices of
how we can run the board by even being
in better and leader myself and my
friend job without a doubt it was worth
coming and without a doubt
I've enhanced my skill set by being here
when I think about the boards that I sit
on and what I brought to those boards
before this course and what I will bring
to the boards after this course really
shows that there is a lot to be learned